hulot
abdelkarim yacoubou koundougou me et
chercheur associé au groupe afrique et
deux villes se il est avec nous en
direct sur rt france
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
lors on va tout d'abord revenir sur les
propos de la ministre française de la
transition écologique elle qui préfère
insister 1 sur les avancées permises par
ce rassemblement international même si
elle pense qu'on n'est pas allé assez
loin
en effet on peut dire qu'il ya eu des
petites avancées pas de grande avancée
mieux que rien a dire si la ministre est
satisfaite parce que pour la première
fois on a réussi à régler le problème de
l'application de l'accord de paris
c'étaient les défauts qui avait ça c'est
une avancée maintenant l'insuffisance
est de savoir comment on va appliquer
cela et qui va respecter et dans quels
délais l'accord de paris dit qu'il faut
atteindre les 1,5 degrés au maximum
d'ici 2050 et le cateau voit
l'engagement et la déclaration de
beaucoup des états émetteurs de cette
position comme la chine l'inde la russie
la chine dit que 2070 l'année dès 2060
la russie a viz encore plus cela montre
très bien que si le principe est accepté
l'application prendra encore du temps et
chacun au sortir de cette crise de covin
vais protéger d'abord son économie les
climats n'est pas la priorité de tous
ses états ce moment alors oui c'est vrai
que c'est un peu unanimement cette coque
26 n'est pas allé assez loin mais il ya
quand même sur le papier ce sont des
mots qui sont inscrits en dans cette
déclaration au final ya les mots
combustibles fossiles il ya le mot
charbon ce sont là les principaux
responsables de ce réchauffement
climatique c'est peut-être ça aussi la
bonne avancée
oui les bonnes intentions ça n'a pas
manqué mais seulement est ce que les
intentions suffisent c'est ça la glande
je sais cela à tout le monde à la bonne
intention de sauver la planète tout le
monde les s'engager
on va très bien que au delà de cet
engagement comment on va très bien qu'il
ya des accords et des bilatéraux les
gens discutent entre puissances les gens
essayent de trouver des solutions à
leurs problèmes à leurs économies mais
l'application des textes et tout le
monde accepte d'appliquer laconiquement
l'accord de paris on va y arriver d'ici
2050 une réduction au maximum de deux
degrés mais si dans le cas échéant si
personne ne respecte ce délai de 2050
l'augmentation de la température pour
atteindre 2,8 ou même trois degrés de
plus d'un c'est lamentable à 7,17 chose
c'est que aujourd'hui ses états qui sont
émetteurs ces états qui sont
responsables de ce qui se passe ne
veulent pas justement s'est plié à ces
règles c'est ce qui a été décidé alors
combien chacun donne des exceptions donc
si les personnes ne respectent les
principes et tout le monde veut des
exceptions et bien
le principe d'application ne suffit pas
il faut respecter le délai tout le monde
dit que 2050 la dernière ligne droite et
la ligne rouge qu'il ne faut pas
dépasser
on voit très bien que pendant toute la
conférence de grade et glasgow personne
ne veut respecter cela c'est ça le lundi
kablia c'est le manquement et le pire
c'est que le pays pauvres qui sont en
première ligne qui est la conséquence de
ce non respect font qu'aujourd'hui
serait qu'ils sont en pleine ligne est
personne ne les écoute d'ailleurs ils
sont même déçus de ce qui s'est passé
parce que depuis 2009 avant même la
conférence de de départ et il ya eu des
engagements pour soutenir ces états afin
d'affronter et d'atténuer ses
conséquences et depuis 2009 on a très
bien qu'ils ces états qui sont engagés
donner 5 milliards à ces pays pauvres
personnes à respecter ses engagements
oui c'était en 2009 1 vous lisiez les
promesses il y avait été prise par les
pays riches ont donc c'était il ya plus
de dix ans maintenant et maintenant ils
sont jean oui et maintenant ils se sont
de nouveau engagés encore un donner de
l'argent mais rien n'indique clairement
qu'ils le feront d'ailleurs le
représentant du kenya qui assistait donc
à cette coop 26 l'a dit notre confiance
a été brisée est ce que pour vous les
pays en développement sont les grands
oubliés de cette coop 26
ce n'est pas seulement les grands
oubliés madame c'est les grands perdants
les grands sacrifiés de 7.6 on en a très
bien vu que finalement on n'écoute pas
ses états ils sont en train de tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé
on n'écoute pas ses états qui disent
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous êtes encore en
train de discuter pour sauver vos
économies nous c'est des centaines des
milliers de personnes qui meurent chaque
année à cause des nouveaux engagements
ne sont pas respectés donc c'est dans
cette galère on a dit que finalement ça
ne sert même plus à venir pour crier
puisque depuis 2009 et savent la réalité
ils savent les conséquences et savent
les difficultés de ces états qui sont en
train de souffrir et qui sont en
première ligne de cette crise climatique
qui s'entraîne aussi pointé et bien si
la digue cède surtout la digue dans le
sahel et dans tous ses points delà du
continent qui sont en train d'être cédée
eh bien ça sert elle on a atteint le
point de non retour
donc c'est les états des pays pauvres ne
peuvent que alerter sur leur situation
et si en face des états qui s'engagent
depuis dix ans à vouloir faire quelques
jeux qui ne font pas et bien finalement
n'est pas de l'humanité a calé ces pays
pauvres qui demandent mais des
engagements forts pour que la situation
de combien la responsabilité climatiques
de ces états émetteurs de pollution soit
engagé je crois que ces pays là vont
atteindre ce niveau où on doit
poursuivre en justice des états qui ne
respectent pas un engagement qui
émettent des
ddd 2 des émissions polluantes et que
les conséquences sur les autres et a
finalement donc si les préférant ne
suffira pas je suis certain que ces
états du pays pauvres du sud qui
encaisse cette conséquence ils ont un
justicier jours oui les pays pauvres en
éléments responsables du réchauffement
première ligne face à ces impacts
abdelkerim yacoub koundougou milk merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle vous êtes chercheur associé au
groupe afrique de lips merci